there's a very very beautiful story
Buddha
so the statement is that one day a young
monk came
in the hour where people could go and
ask questions and said
and
passed him and it's very beautiful it
says he sat down and said he says I was
meditating the other day
and the following thoughts came to me I
should have looked this up before a
conversation because I will probably not
reproduce completely right but his name
was
as well sir I was thinking about this
and the following thoughts are quarterly
why is it is the universe finite
or did it have a beginning
was did it always existed I mean so is
it finite in time or what he's a
universe finite in space or is it
infinite
the other questions that we asked today
right yeah it is amazing
then he goes on about eight questions
that's why it's actually looked up the
other questions these were the first two
questions and then he sort of says that
well there's
Buddha
exists after the after death or would
that not exist after death or Buddha
exists both exist not at our exists so
it goes on in
first of the outer world and then you
know with the more
um
spiritual questions
Buddha doesn't answer
keeps quiet
then his mother is disappointed
so he's Waits there very respectfully
for whatever time was supposed to be
appropriate and then leaves
comes back a week later says I'm sorry
but I
those questions continue to bother me I
am really troubled and he repeats the
questions again they say yes I think
that one or eight questions again sounds
like me
so Buddha doesn't answer again
and
then and third time he comes and he says
the every time I come I ask this
question she repeats the question he
says
it should be simple for you to say
that you know the answers or you don't
know the answers and if you know the
answers what they are
your silence does not please me that was
the one one phrase he says
and basically
something that if it doesn't get his
answers he will leave the Sangha you
know the community
and Buddha replies
he says first of all you didn't join
Sangha conditionally
but of course if you want to leave you
can leave any time anybody can give any
time nobody is born here
and secondly the reason I don't answer
those questions
is because they have nothing to do
the central
problems
that that this Sangha is all about and
it has to do with
sufferings
understanding those questions
and understanding answers to those
questions or exploring them and
understanding them sufficientness will
do nothing to reduce reduction of
yourself right
and then I think Buddha gives an analogy
he says
there is supposing you that you you go
and
now I forget details but you are wounded
by an arrow
and then the doctor comes and doctor
wants to put something to eat some
medicine
so you say no don't put me in the bed
don't put the medicine first I have to
know where did you get those plants
how long were these plants marinated why
this plant and not some some other plant
as this medicine been used always if it
was not used always why did it start
using now and what changes and so on so
but if you do that he says you will die
before you're cured
he said the same thing is true
with this questions about the external
world
now what I like about this
is not that he belittle the questions
about external world
religious honestly said that this is not
what is what is above I mean it's like
if you like it's like saying that you
know somebody comes to physics class and
asks questions about
Neuroscience of allergy or something and
you know I we don't know the answers to
those questions you're in the wrong
place
so I think
so there's a there's a there's really a
system there is a really division
between this external world and internal
world and it has grown
all right I mean like
uh transferabilities and you know it's
the same several centuries it has it has
grown
and
I think it's a Pity because on the other
hand we are all human beings and we see
the external world and we we have the
internal world we cannot just deny the
internal world you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy